الخوض البيضاء اعلنت انها ستواصل البحث عن
ناجين تحت الانقاذ رغم صعوبه الامر
فالزلزال يدخل يومه الخامس ما يعادل 120
ساعه
حتميا فرص نجاه العالقين تحت الانقاض شبه
معدومه حيث تعتبر اول اثنتين وسبعين ساعه
بعد الزلزال اي اول ثلاثه ايام اطارا
زمنيا حرجا
وينخفض بعد ذلك معدل البقاء على قيد
الحياه الى ما بين خمسه الى عشره بالمئه
وبحسب خبراء الكوارث الطارئه تعتبر
الاثنتان والسبعون ساعه الاولى بعد
الكارثه هي الفتره التي يمكن للانسان ان
يعيش خلالها بقوه جسديه دون طعام او ماء
يبلغ معدل البقاء على قيد الحياه 90% خلال
اول 24 ساعه وخمسين الى 60% بين 25 و 48
ساعه وعشرين الى ثلاثين بالمئه بين 49
واثنتين وسبعين ساعه اما بعد الاثنتين
وسبعين ساعه فيكون معدل البقاء على قيد
الحياه ما بين خمسه الى عشره بالمئه او
اقل
وفي الكوارث عاده ما يتم الغاء معظم جهود
الانقاذ بعد خمسه الى سبعه ايام فالعثور
على شخص ما خلال هذه الساعات الذهبيه كما
يقال هي مساله حياه او موت وتعتبر سباقا
مع الزمن